the new US president is probably none
too pleased that Germany exports a lot
more than it imports and has done so for
decades in 2016 Germany's trade surplus
equalled 7.7 percent of the country's
GDP in Trump's world one country surplus
equals another country's deficits and
deficits mean less production slower
economic activity and job loss in those
countries consider trade between Germany
and the United States German exports to
the u.s. keep growing year on year
especially machines cars and
pharmaceuticals sales in the other
direction are worth just half as much
between January and November last year
Germany sold 56 billion euros more to
the US than had bought that makes the US
Germany's biggest export market about a
million German jobs are estimated to
depend on it the European Union doesn't
like the trade surplus either EU
agreements allow for a maximum of just 6
percent of GDP in fact one of the
union's governing bodies the EU
Commission should begin proceedings
against Germany to stop it
but the Commission doesn't want to
antagonize Germany and has delayed so
far
and Germany isn't taking steps to reduce
the surplus on the contrary
manufacturers are balking at renewed
employee wage demands so that German
companies remain competitive in
international markets businesses and
manufacturers have no intention of
reducing exports economic pressure to
maintain a trade surplus is strong given
that Germany offers a wide range of
goods that are in demand worldwide at
the same time Germany is doing nothing
to increase imports compared to other
countries the government is not
investing much in infrastructure
experience shows that more investment
would boost imports and reduce surplus
none of this interests the new US
president Trump wants to force German
companies like BMW to produce their
products in the US if they want to
continue to sell their
[Music]
you